>>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S NOT OKAY,
USING SOMEONE'S MENTAL HEALTH
STRUGGLES AS A WEAPON WHEN YOU
ATTACK THEM FOR, BASICALLY, YOU
DON'T HAVE AN ARGUMENT AGAINST
THEM.
SO YOU JUST SAY THEY ARE NUTS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DOING WITH
KANYE WEST.
HIS POLITICAL VIEWS NOT ALL THAT
IMPORTANT.
YOU JUST HURL INSULTS AT HIM TO
TRY TO DEMONIZE HIM.
IT IS SIMPLY DISGUSTING.
>> THIS WAS AN EMBARRASSMENT.
KANYE'S MOTHER IS ROLLING OVER
IN HER GRAVE.
>> NOT ONLY WAS THIS A CRAZY
CONVERSATION FOR THIS WHITE
HOUSE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF CONVERSATION
THAT WOULD TYPICALLY BE HELD
BETWEEN PEOPLE WEARING HOSPITAL
BRACELETS.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS OPEN TO
HELP.
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS A PUBLIC CRY
FOR HELP.
HE IS NOT GETTING ANY HELP.
>> THERE WAS A RANTING LUNATIC
IN THE OVAL OFFICE TODAY.
>> KANYE, BACK AWAY FROM THE
CAMERAS.
GO GET SOME HELP AND THEN COME
BACK AND MAKE YOUR CASE.
>> GET HELP?
DR. LEMON, WHY ARE YOU
STIGMATIZING PEOPLE WHO BATTLE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
HOW DARE YOU FRY TO MINIMIZE
WHAT HE IS SAYING BECAUSE HE IS
OPEN ABOUT SOME OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES HE IS HAVING.
DON LEMON IS A GOOD GUY.
JOINING ME, PATRICK CORYGAN,
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK "THE STIGMA
EFFECT QUIT.
HOW DELETERIOUS IS IT FOR ANYONE
IN THE RIGHT WING OR LEFT WING
TO EXPLOIT ANOTHER PERSON'S
MEDICAL HISTORY AS WAS DONE OVER
THE PAST 24 HOURS REGARDING
KANYE WEST?
>> REDUCING SOMEBODY'S
CONVERSATION TO IL LEGITIMACY BY
SAYING THEY ARE MENTALLY ILL IS
IN THE SAME CATEGORY AS STIGMA
RELATED TO RACISM, SEXISM, HOMO
PHOBIA, IT IS SAYING YOUR
MESSAGE DOESN'T COUNT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE HAD AN ISSUE WITH
BIPOLAR DISORDER OR MENTAL
ILLNESS.
PEOPLE LABELED ARE UNABLE TO GET
JOBS, LIVE INDEPENDENTLY, GET
GOOD HEALTH CARE.
IT IS ALL BECAUSE MESSAGES LIKE
THIS PERPETUATE THEM AS BEING
DIFFERENT OR WORSE THAN WE ARE.
>> PROFESSOR, IT SEEMS LIKE IT
WOULD DETER PEOPLE FROM GETTING
COUNSELING.
LET'S SAY THEY LOST A PARENT,
WENT THROUGH A DIFFICULT TIME,
IF THEY KNOW LATER ON THEY ARE
GOING TO BE DESCRIBED AS ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO GOT HELP.
AS SOMEONE WHO KNOWS A LOT OF
PEOPLE OVER THE YEARS WHO HAVE
GONE THROUGH INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT PERIOD OF TIME, WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO TALK
TO OTHERS, TO GET HELP.
TO ME, IN THIS CASE, ITS MOSTLY
LIBERALS SADLY IN THIS SITUATION
WHO ARE DEMONIZING SOMEONE JUST
BECAUSE, I GUESS, THEY ARE IN
THE OVAL OFFICE WITH TRUMP AND
THROWN IN THE CRAZYTOWN DEAL AS
A WAY TO DEMONIZE HIM AND
DISMISS HIM.
>> ANY TIME YOU THROW IN THE
WORD CRAZY, WHETHER IT COMES
FROM THE LEFT OR THE RIGHT, IT
UNDERMINES THE OPPORTUNITIES OF
PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS.
BY THE WAY, THAT'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
EPIDEMIOLOGY SUGGESTS IT COULD
BE ONE OUT OF FIVE PEOPLE HAVE A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
THE STIGMA FUNDAMENTALLY COMES
FROM THE LABEL.
I AM SEEING SOMEBODY COME OUT OF
THE PSYCHIATRIST OFFICE AND I
KNOW THEY MUST BE NUTS OR COMING